il n'y a plus rien sanctionné en russie
déploré encore en octobre dernier le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de la
maison blanche robert au bras yen mais
qui s'arrêtent devant si modique
difficulté un think tank russe le
conseil russe pour les affaires
internationales a tenté d'analyser les
conséquences du régime de sanctions
bonne nouvelle pour les russes
cette politique de mesures punitives se
stabilise pour la deuxième année
consécutive la politique de sanctions à
l'encontre de la russie revêt un
caractère stable aucune escalade
significative des sanctions ne s'est
produite jusqu'à présent en tout cas les
sanctions actuelles n'ont pas d'impact
significatif sur la situation
macroéconomique ni celle micro
économique en russie et n'entraîne pas
de fluctuations importantes du marché se
tenir face à la pandémie et oublier les
désaccords un an la pandémie du coran
navires us selon les auteurs du rapport
n'a pas influencé la politique de
sanctions pour ce qui est de nouveau
prétexte la sphère navalni ou des
attaques présumées de hackers russes et
crée des tensions politiques sans
réellement touché l'économie russe
l' attaque contre north stream 2 par
exemple n'a pas pour le moment conduit à
l'arrêt du projet mais on ne peut pas
exclure un scénario vraiment mauvais
toutefois les relations entre la russie
et ses opposants occidentaux restent
tendues elles sont marquées par une
vulnérabilité face aux nouvelles crises
et aux sanctions qui en découle sans
raisons politiques sérieuses il n'y aura
pas de sanctions draconiennes imposées
contre la russie cependant le scénario
d'une escalade soudaine et dramatique
des relations avec une augmentation
qualitative de la pression des sanctions
ne peut toujours pas être écartée qu'on
sait pour les dirigeants russes de la
part des scientifiques et il faudrait
continuer doucement la dédollarisation
qui est déjà en cours développer un
système de paiement national
perfectionner les savoir-faire des
contres sanctions et approfondir un
dialogue concernant les restrictions
avec la chine cible est le cd sanctions
américaines
l'impact relativement faible des
sanctions sur la stabilité macro
économique s'accompagne de risques
élevés pour les entreprises ou les
projets individuels la gestion du risque
lié aux sanctions demeure la
préoccupation la plus importante de la
direction d'une entreprise
mais comme on dit en russie qui ne
prends pas le risque ne sabre pas le
champagne